you know my favorite thing to do when I
would go on with a lot of men I would
get like a meatball sandwich you know
I'm really like a giant meatball
sandwich and they would say Letterman's
coming down a hole I'm like oh and I
stand in front of makeup okay get that
disgusting sandwich out of here how can
you eat you're going on in 10 minutes oh
let's go home and then I would bring the
sandwich out on stage you know and just
surprise on this meatballs no I don't
want any meatballs I mean it was just so
much fun but I think he lied I think he
liked the fact that I could be loud and
verbose and loquacious yeah that wasn't
his thing so and I admired his ability
to be a Wordsmith you know I always
remember his great joke about
um
local editorials you remember this
Letterman bit about we here at station
whatever are opposed to the use of
Orphans as yardage markers on public
golf courses you know and I I thought
what what a clever series